what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we're here to watch the second episode of
The Last of Us once again joined by my buddy man
who have talked about this game with constantly
over the years Andrew Gordon Igor 7-Eleven how
you feeling Andrew I'm feeling good and Craig's
line that's all we ever talk about it's just
the last of us when he calls me says Hey Last
of Us ladies and gentlemen you know it's due
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when I reaction for the
next episode of The Last of Us is up here on
the channel as always full anthraction watch
along as we sync it with your own copy of The
Last of Us available for our super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page we'll recover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included Thanksgiving another disclaimer
here if this is your first time watching with us
yes we play the game but we will not spoil
anything that could possibly happen in the
future of the show since this show seems to be
pretty faithful to the actual Source material
we'll only talk about specifically this episode
anything about how correlated the game itself
and another mention John and Tara Erickson who
haven't played the game will be continuing their
reactions right here on this very Channel
this week alrighty guys let's get to it
20 30. Indonesia two days
before outbreak day interesting
is she a scientist or something
Professor mycology okay yeah all right feels like
Matthew Broderick and Godzilla
when he's studying worms foreign
oh
get out now
that was a really good addition I love that yeah
Gore um
you got 48 hours
foreign
back to what really matters that's a really
great openness especially with you know like
how sci-fi the world is and makes it feel that
much more real when you do stuff like that in
the video games we'd only been told about how
they studied it and learned about it and now
actually seeing it and also in a different
country too worldwide spread yeah exactly
we're also seeing a scientist like understand
the ramifications like we're we're screwed
oh wow foreign
like just waiting for her to turn do I
look like I'm infected choose your arm
I like this interesting add-on yeah
it's not getting any worse is it
what was Marlene doing with an
infected kid I'm not infected
test you how I have to pee test you you know
I think what really impressed him was the
fact that I didn't turn into a [__]
monster back there you can find a spot
in here oh yeah I have to learn
to trust tear out a few pages
there's not gonna be anything just you are funny
I feel like something bad in there is a reference
to uh something that happens later on in the game
you need to stop talking about this kid like
she's got some kind of life in front of her
is that chicken yeah probably
until they get it from Smugglers
that's not you guys
we're doing this for us because because
apparently you're worth something but we
don't know what you're worth if we don't know
what we have so answer my question you told
me not to tell anybody that I'm telling the
first people that we've heard this a million
times vaccines miracle cures none of it works
thank you man I didn't ask for this you and me
both this isn't going to end well test I
was so Ellie if they believed that she is
we get what we want oh you'd be
hoping she so much as twitches
I'm loving the Rapport between
the three of them fella Rhymes
is great can I have a gun absolutely not okay
throw a sandwich at them
yes
oh yeah
even the door opening sounds like
a clicker it's foreshadowing yeah
goodness the attention to
detail it's it's unbelievable
yeah that looks so real yeah
km HBO you don't throw down we should get moving
oh I'm a dick is this where they bombed yeah
they hit most of the big cities like this
look at that God damn the detail I know the
attention to detail it's really unbelievable
pure Recreation long way or short way
it's the long way or the whiff and dead
way well I thought long way is based
on that limited information foreign
so it was just you in there alone
yeah ah how old are you 14. same age is in the
game mommy you got some balls on you sister
thanks I like fleshing out the
relationship more there's a lot
more character moments in this for sure
watching it grow nobody's gonna be coming
after you right like Mom boyfriend
I'm an orphan and uh no no boyfriend
did that reference so there aren't super
infected that explode fungus spores on you
or ones with split open heads that see in the
dark like bats will we see that this episode
what was that
say it let's keep moving just identify
it I just want to hear you say the words
oh my God looks just like the hotel I know it's
amazing oh my God that's really cool they got
Neil druckman to direct this you want to stay in
a place like this uh no a little out of our league
I don't even know what this is have you heard of
books wait are we going in there yeah we gotta get
to the stairwell on the other side can't swim
I I don't know how to swim how'd you know that
so gross I love the sense of awe and the feeling
of Adventure that Bella Ramsay's able to emote
kind of sweet please yes ma'am
right away man I'm a weird kid
foreign
look at his reaction to that
hey are you sure I have touched her you know if
there's also the feeling of the intimacy of that
the anticipation
what the [__] did that happen
gotta search the place one of
the fun Parts well I mean maybe I
could climb up there yeah yep yes
never thought I'd be so excited about
a boost I'm gonna need a few minutes
awkward
where'd you learn to do that the circus
where are you from a forced conversation what
about tests Detroit it's in Michigan
I go to school I know where Detroit is
how long do infected live Oh I thought you
went to school it's a really shitty one
well some last about a month or two but
there's others been walking around but 20 years
what now
oh there's a swarm of them put them in danger
do you respect the choice to shoot
a lot of this handheld gives it a
little bit more of an disorienting real feeling
wow oh my God that's a lot of bodies
that is insane that's a disturbing image
oh the sky the fungus also grows
underground you step on a patch of
cordyceps in one place and you can wake
a dozen infected wow interesting you're
not immune from being ripped apart it's
important I'm trying to keep you alive I
like how she's becoming a bit of a mother
but she knows how important she is Museum
whoa
It's like Neil druckman's wet dream come alive
it's bone dry could mean they're
all finally dead in there
it's a really interesting new detail we learned
congratulations
such a shot I love how weary and beaten Pedro
Pascal's interpretation is
he's just like depressed
or in the museum guys we're in the
museum this is awesome oh the tension
oh just a hat remaining there yeah oh
did he leave a letter yeah
that's pretty fresh body
here okay from this point forward
not quiet oh it's good
yikes
wow
be quiet
man this production design
is phenomenal it's amazing
oh my goodness
you're making so much noise just a little bit
God
oh that noise effects
goodness
oh my goodness
attention never been so excited for
people in such a scary situation
damn they got the body
language down perfectly yeah
oh she's gonna freak out
damn that's scary shoot the head
he's surviving longer than you would in the game
that is terrifying
hey Captain oh is this smart smart or a little
tougher to defeated in real life than in the game
oh I love the specifics here
no
oh no
I'm loving it
oh my God it's like Ellie show
man yeah use your knife Ellie
no
foreign
yes they are much more tougher
to kill than this you're right
you all right I love how they
captured so much of that just from
our character's perspective I didn't
[__] my pants we're with you Ellie
you think change again she should get
bit every episode see nothing's happening
oh I think you guys are going to need a plank
they have a plank already in place
oh my goodness did you just take
the good news I did it for once
maybe we can actually win we'll
just go and go and watch her hope
it's interesting seeing someone
put Joel on his place though
oh a test
is it everything you hoped for jury's still out
uh yeah
come on the Ellie Angel they're doing it man
they've really succeeded haven't they this is
this is great this is great looked at the watch
that was a nice little moment right there just
some nice little subtle detail reminded of Sarah
getting close to the Capitol Building or the
State Building as they call them this one
oh oh I just saw something
oh yes
uh man imagine going through
all that I mean it's got to be a
radio or something right in the
game she said a map or something
the healthy ones fought the sick
ones everyone lost one of them's
got to have a map on them yeah
Tess it's over we are going home
it's coming our luck had to run out
sooner or later one more episode yeah
it sounded just like Ellie show me
wow this is like word for word
yeah oh no take your bandage off
it's smart to have her get bit again I
need you to get her to Bill and Frank's
he'll take her off your hands they'll
handle it from here no no no I can't
they won't take her they're not gonna take
her cause you'll convince them man please
oh
oh no oh no
what an interesting that was
a really interesting addition
oh my God it makes sense now they
just don't react to sounds it's like
a signal definitely a big change from the game too
yes Tess
wow
you
have to
oh
man this one is harder
oh later turned on please
oh come on
oh are we getting stalkers looks like it
oh
God yes
oh wow
that is amazing go Tess
meet your new daughter
as it's the connected mouth-to-mouth
made sense that is disturbing yeah
I thought they were gonna cut right
before we got they're so glad that they
wow
jeez that was nuts yeah my the pacing
of this show never feels like the actual
length that it is yeah yeah that
was gripping oh man that was uh
you know like because it was crazy because
that's as seen in the end is like when when
she reveals that she's been bit in the game you
mean in the game is like it's like word for word
but it actually hit me much harder here because
of the amount of time we've spent with Tess and
developing her and the scenes all the scenes
combined uh and and because because it seems
that I remember the first time playing the game
and being like oh this is really sad that kind of
I kind of saw this coming like the first time I
played like I predicted that this would probably
happen um saw two to my own horn it just felt like
that's probably what's gonna happen yeah and here
though I found myself going please don't kill her
off this episode I know she has to die yeah but
well can we just like you know maybe stretch that
thing out to like a later episode can we hear like
what my third episode because she's so good yeah
and I was so invested in her and uh I was actually
gonna I never like got like super emotional uh
when in the game but in here that that definitely
I was getting a little misty out when it happened
yeah you make a good point I mean we get a lot
more character moments especially between the
three of them whereas in the game again we still
got some character moments in the game for sure it
was still really good but here it's it's stretched
out a lot more we get like just I mean we get that
awkward conversation between Joel and and Ellie
and then again the conversation just where they're
having the sandwiches it's just again just really
good rapport and really good character moments I
really love the addition at the beginning of the
episode where we're seeing like the worldwide
effect of right before outbreak Dave where the
scientist uh is studying it and like oh my like
bomb the city like I just I thought that was such
an interesting touch because again in the video
game it was just touched upon that again it's
the quarter steps disease they studied it and you
know we don't really know like we didn't really
get to see this uh the scientists studying it so
to see the effect like before it happens it just
it adds a different layer now that you can put in
your head when you play play the game like oh now
I know what what happened a couple days before
I know what the scientists went through and like
the explanation of it and I just I really again
this is I apologize this is probably the last
time I'm going to mention this I really hope did
someone at Disney is watching this show and just
having an understanding this is how live action
remakes that they do I this is how it should be
done again we're only two episodes in you know
we still got seven more episodes but I'm just I'm
really you're gonna hear this from me a lot I'm
loving the additions that they make some of the
changes that they make yes there are some things
that they're a word for word line for line there
are some things that they're doing but they're
doing it you know sporadically they're not doing
it it doesn't feel it doesn't oh sorry to cut you
off I was just on that point like it doesn't feel
perfunctory it doesn't feel like we have to do
this it like seamlessly weaves in to a word for
word moment yes like like when they're looking
at the the tower after the clicker scene or
thank you um yeah on the plank like that whole
scene was like wow that's right from the game or
or the scene when Tess reveals that she's been
bitten like that's right from the game I mean
they've obviously changed some stuff at the end
but they it I love that it never just it never
feels like there's doing from the game because
they have to do it from the game it they the way
they they transition into him like oh man I would
have I would it never feels out of place like if
I've never played the game I would never question
the scene or something like that where I'm like
are they the scene feels odd are they only doing
it because it's something with the game it is so
natural it feels completely natural but they've
added some [__] in here like with the rules of
we learned uh from heavy spoilers breakdown that
they're gonna there's not gonna be spores which is
a bummer to me but they've added there's a whole
other thing with like a hive mind yeah where you
know what's that a signal like that is really
that's interesting actually because again in
the games we'd uh we'd learn like oh no they react
obviously we know clickers you know they they only
they react to echolocation they can only hear you
know sound like a bat but we figured in the game
that they only come when they hear noises they're
going to come towards you and that perspective
but now like this whole thing where you know the
spores come Underground when they feel like one
of them has died and now sends out a signal
to the other one's laying on the ground like
that's really provocative that's interesting
like that's a cool new layer to it it makes the
it adds a new layer of it's like it's a great
way to supplement the whole thing of sports
with something else yeah for sure that enhances
the the the idea of of sneaking around because
you know like in the games and [__] like you
have stuff where your plane is old you can like
hear really far away and everything listen mode
yeah yeah yeah you could enhance that whatever
um so to add to add different obstacles and
different Stakes to the equation of something
like that is is gnarly and yeah I mean of course
you got to address the thing uh for for gamers
that the way they because yeah at the end like
Tess is like you guys go and uh but it's oh God
who who shows it's civil guys show up it's fedra
I think it's Federal it's definitely guys I don't
know it's either hunters or it's fed red so it's
one of them something like that but it's obviously
it's not infected in the video game like this but
this wasn't I like the change made here well it
made something that felt more it felt Bleaker
felt a little bit more poetic uh for her to go
out like that and we got to see it too rather
than like it was just in the background where
you know if you get in the video game she got shot
and then we saw from Joel and Ellie's perspective
oh no she's been shot and like what like now you
gotta run but like actually seeing it it just it
was more gut-wrenching exactly it was way more
heartbreaking and uh it's so much more Bleak the
way she dies this way too as well just exactly
what with the lighter that's a great call yeah
yeah I mean uh erupting It Up in Flames with the
things she's about to become you know like she she
takes them all out before she becomes this thing
that is literally connecting to her pretty much
welcoming her in to the new family you're part
of this courtesy fungi family now and she just
won't she rejects it it's it's insane and I love
the direction by Neil druckman on this because
the way he toys with perspective especially like
with the is that for sure a stalker looks like a
stalker it was a stock yeah for sure but the
way the stalker um comes into frame like how
it's it's over her shoulder but it's blurred for
a while before it comes in a frame or like the
scene with the clickers he usually he locks on the
the and then the first episode does this a lot too
they lock on to perspective of a character
we're watching in the scene and how they're
experiencing and witnessing similar to like when
you're playing a game and you're getting a POV
experience you you see it through the characters
povs on things without just like cutting directly
to them a lot of the time like sometimes you
do but more often than not you're just with
the characters yeah well I think it adds a lot of
tension too I just I keep feeling like 80s or 70s
John Carpenters directing these scenes uh the the
horror scenes I mean it's just amazing and we got
to talk also about the stalkers and the clickers
the attention to detail if we talked about the the
visual details in terms of the museum the planks
and all that other stuff the the sound design
the clickers the stalkers it's it's it's just so
beautiful it's real it's it's it's it's daunting
It's haunting it's scary but it's so beautiful at
this same page it is beautiful because you're like
it's it's it's mesmerized I I mean it is cured
like we have John and Tara doing reactions uh
for who haven't played the game but from like a
from people who are in love with the game it is
beautiful it's mesmerizing when you're like wow
they've really brought the thing I love to life
you know it's it's in it's gnarly and I can only
imagine for Neil druckman to be experiencing this
like didn't I direct this before oh no no this is
better well I think did he direct them I know he
directed the second game did he direct the first
I believe he directed for sure the director of
that one there was you made a point while we
were watching that I like was thinking in the
moment but you said it first the body land body
movements and body language of the people and the
click the the stunt people doing the the clicker
Motions like it was spot on just spot on they
should make a an immersive experience I think they
should do something they should build something
where you I would gladly pay like fifty dollars
to go like I'll do a walkthrough let's go let's
do this thing it'd be awesome to see if brought
to life because clearly they can do it because
yeah I mean when I was looking at this the the
buildings and stuff you're like okay yeah that
has to be green screens there's no way they build
that [__] so it has to be green screen the green
screen is is impeccable there's only a few times
I could tell with some of the king like okay yeah
that's definitely a green screen but more often
than not it's seamlessly yeah you cannot tell
it it Blends so well the production design is
phenomenal especially too when you see like
the spores and the wall I mean not the spores
but like the the remains in the wall of people
who uh become infected it's like yeah it's so
it's so phenomenal it's the production design
like absolutely fantastic in this show and I
just again this episode was great I I really
love you also mentioned too during the beginning
of the episode like it's interesting to see the
beginning of the episode start from the past
how they were doing a little bit of non-linear
storytelling so I'm hoping like that's something
that they keep continuing on I hope that I mean
we're talking also too about possibly seeing
like uh where we did another video maybe seeing
like Tommy's perspective oh sorry cut that
we're not going to talk about that actually
um but you know going back to what I was just
saying um just I thought you made a really I
mean the trailers they show you it's credited
in IMDb and they're sharing the trailers of War
I imagine would see the day without spoiling
anything I'd imagine we'd and they mentioned
the character in the last episode so I feel like
we can slightly say this Riley they mentioned the
name Riley in the last episode and I feel like
would probably get a flashback where we get to
see of course so we're definitely getting that
but I mean again I just I like how they're really
setting it up with okay we're gonna focus at least
so far through two episodes we're gonna focus on
moments in the past a little bit of non-linear
storytelling and then go back to the present I
I think it's a nice touch I like it because it
it sets the mood and the tone for the rest of
the episode well I also love there's so much to
love about this show like there's nothing there's
nothing I don't like about it it's even like I
had a little bit of I I had it as I really liked
Bello Ramsay in the in the first episode I imagine
there's a lot of people who loved her right away
I really liked her and this episode I was like on
board I love her yeah and um and then when you go
even the littlest especially felt it with the
clicker scene and and it's Joel and Ellie and
they're duck down together I'm like oh my God
it's Ellie and Joe like that moment right there
was and then from then on out yeah I just had that
moment with the show of they did it they did the
most important thing to me and I think for you
too it's like yeah with Beyond just bringing the
visuals there's so much you have to nail yeah but
one of the most important things you gotta nail is
Ellie and Joel the most important thing you got
to bring them to life they got to make it their
own and they gotta have great chemistry and and I
had those aha moments of yeah that's that's them
they've brought my favorite video game characters
to life and in a way that does again that doesn't
feel like you know cosplay or some [__] like
that yes it feels like they've it's cool it's so
cool how they they made it their own yet it feels
like it's completely honoring the source material
that was one of the things I loved about Gabriel
Luna I hope I said the name right this time yeah
that's one of the things I loved about Gabriel
Luna in the first episode like is that Jeffrey
Pierce talking or is that Gabriel lunatucky it's
just like him but no I agree with you like I
liked uh Bella Ramsay in the first episode but
this episode just playing again the very first
scene she had yeah you're like oh she's selling
yeah yeah the the character moments but not only
that it's just the way she's again the foul mouth
smart ass that she's being I'm like this is just
Ellie Ellie Ellie it's like ah I love it and again
the reporter and Joel have just that one little
awkward conversation that scene was so endearing
I really enjoyed that a lot I just where Tess
was uh trying to get the door open and they were
just having that conversation came to know each
other a little like this is how it begins their
relationship oh I love that well that scene I
mean riffing off of that that's kind of what I
of why I was so invested in Tess even more is
because they're letting you earn the relationships
much like they're spending so much more time yeah
like when you play the games the first game is
significantly shorter compared to the second game
significantly the second game is like Infinity it
feels like it won't end and I love it yes I agree
whereas whereas the first game you know uh you
don't you definitely don't spend this much time
with develop with allowing you to earn the trust
with Ellie like for our for Tess and Joel they
I wouldn't say they speed through it because they
suddenly don't speed through it but you get there
quicker correct and here they really take their
time like them having a standoff with her when she
wakes up oh that was beautiful wonderful addition
because they're like we have no idea what you are
and and what's going on in your child and even
with Joel having to really learn so the addition
of her getting bitten again like in the game she
just says like this was three weeks ago right yeah
but but to have it be that much more of a concrete
proof for an instant yeah test you're right she
did just get she got bit a while ago and uh she
just got bit like now and it was like an hour ago
and also Tess just had been bitten an hour ago
and you can tell the difference on which one is
periodically way worse yeah yeah and so having
that immediate parallel between the two bites
works much stronger in this medium uh when
you're doing your adaptation so yeah again I'd
like another another great addition to it yeah no
I mean it's just they're just making again through
two episodes such smart choices just things
they're adding on things they're subtly changing I
mean they're still being so fate that what I love
about this is they're still being so faithful to
the game while adding and satisfactory and really
smart and interesting things that move the plot
forward and give us Great Character moments
that's all I care about while staying pretty
faithful and they're just achieving on all ends in
every Department in my opinion yeah now they just
gotta find dead bodies and where everyone leaves
letters behind yes and safe and safe so we got to
get those combo locks open there's some good stuff
we got to get them searching around looking for
uh they gotta pick up rails and supplies they're
gonna get a whole bunch of things gotta spend time
with the important stuff here oh they're gonna
do a lot of unnecessary it's like Joel why do
you keep running to every corner of the room you
never know there's every drawer and every Locker
be disappointed once in a while when you spend
time to open it it might be ammo in there yeah
oh there's so much fun to be had yeah uh but no I
mean I feel like it's pretty much everything with
this episode right because it was it was great
they're I think they're doing everything right
that clicker scene was a hard time nail down I I
was really impressed with that clicker scene I'm
really curious too if they got the same people who
did the clicker motion body motion stuff for the
video games like because they do mocap right with
the game yeah and the games of smoke caps I'm like
let's just get the same people back like that's
what I would have done but if they did not get
the same actors or actresses back like whoever
great job either way God I just love that show
whether they're looking at the city and you have
Ellie and Joe dirty oh my God what a it is Ellie
and Joel oh hello so much and also too I wanna
I kind of mentioned a little bit while we were
reacting to it as well I think Bella Ramsay just
does a really good job of also another thing she
nails of Ellie's that sense of awe and Adventure
that she that you can tell also that sense of
fear like when she runs into clickers for the
first time like that's what I feel like she's
got wide range as an actress or she can do all
these different types of emoting and and facial
uh Expressions so I was really impressed while
also getting the smart ass down and and just
again her chemistry with Pedro Pascal there it
really feels like Troll and Ellie I just I I
love it and again love how much of a smart ashy
was all episode just the the Rapport those two
have with each other how they're just bouncing
back and just going at each other it's just it's
pure Joel and Elliott I love it yeah and you can
only feel it growing and also the way Petra Pascal
is doing the role I love just how much more
dejected he is because I I sort of associated
um oh my God Troy Baker uh like Troy Baker's
uh it was a little bit more aggressive I would
say you know what I mean yeah and Churchill's
violent and aggressive here but he's a lot more
um like I said in the direction he's so much
more depressed and it works so well for this
too you know like he's got that edge he's got that
aggression and stuff but you you could feel a lot
more of that sadness on display which is something
maybe you missed just with the idea of like the
the animation uh Department of of a video game
but now I feel like they still get Detroit Baker
just plays a little more aggressive whereas he's
a little more soft-spoken yeah I agree with you
on one other cool detail where I I kind of said I
see something but I didn't want to actually spoil
it I could see when when they were running to
the State Building I could see a little bit of
the bite mark from Tess that's why when I said
I see something so I thought they suddenly like
were hiding it but can yeah I was like maybe
they're gonna see her for episode three yeah
yeah but obviously I wasn't gonna spoil and say
everyone just got a bite marker on her neck but
I like how they subtly weren't kind of showing
but also people who are watching the reaction
I've already seen the episodes but unless of
course it's gonna happen a later episode then we
can't right right of course but still um I thought
that was really well hidden detail that they that
again the attention to detail in this episode and
also too that actress who plays Tess fantastic job
incredible incredible and also too the desperation
and the Hope again how she's able to emote and
give those facial reactions and and have the wide
range I mean these the these actors and actresses
in the show they're through two episodes fantastic
job so far trying to find something I don't like
it's hard I'm really trying to be like what what
don't I'd like damn you Neil druck because this
is so far very compelling and and it doesn't
it's for this thing from disappointing and
again my biggest fear again through two episodes
they've gone past my fears my biggest fears were
are they gonna nail the Joel and Ellie episode
so far through two episodes check and my other
biggest fear is this gonna be a carbon copied
just like the video game and so far check it's
mainly character based which is the game in a
lot of ways but a lot of times with video game
adaptations you're left with the even for games
I haven't played but I watched the movies yeah
I go I'm I feel like I might as well just play
the video like that's how it ends at me because
they focus so much on the the action scenes or
some [__] like that and the story sucks so
much whereas here's the exact opposite it's like
even the way they do the action scenes it's not
making me think oh I'd rather be playing the game
instead like I'm so pulled into the action of how
it's going down that not once am I going I wish I
just had a controller so I was doing this myself
which is a lot of the times video game adaptations
can make me feel so yeah I thought this was uh
this is pretty great so far I hope they keep it
up yeah sure and it's uh I mean yeah the level
of quality of this TV show it's it's fantastic
through two episodes I am so locked into this
I'm loving it all right guys well what did you
think of the second episode leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like and
um check us on patreon we'll catch it all soon
foreign